as long as developers have made
videogames they've hidden secret Easter
eggs in them for their own entertainment
or as a practical joke most of the time
these Easter eggs are intended to be
found but sometimes features in a game
may be scrapped before the title hits
the shelves or unfinished content is
left inside for anyone smart enough to
find it here's a look at some video game
secrets you are never supposed to
discover the mysterious dam in Shadow of
the Colossus this PlayStation 2
adventure title is a cult classic but
developers cut a few things from the
final version of Shadow of the Colossus
but still left them in the code one is a
huge dam that some intrepid hackers
found the structure is immense and looks
pretty complete but nobody knows what it
was intended for maybe it was meant to
house a colossus or possibly just its
shadow it's a mystery all bonds mode in
Goldeneye if the team at rare games
hadn't run into some licensing
difficulties you might have been able to
play as other classic Bond actors
besides Pierce Brosnan in the classic
Nintendo 64 game Goldeneye that's right
the original version of golden I came
with models and textures for Sean
Connery Roger Moore and Timothy Dalton
which you can use in all bonds mode to
play the bonus a [ __ ] tanned Aztec levels
or in multiplayer and the developers
learned the mode had to be scrapped
they held a three-hour deathmatch to
send it off in style hey you got a
license to kill you might as well use it
what gun looks more fitting for a woman
South Park pilot and Tiger Woods 99 PGA
Tour on the PlayStation 2 version of
Tiger Woods 99 PGA Tour a developer
filled out the extra space on the disk
with a dummy file but instead of what
should have been empty space the file
contained a five-minute video of the
South Park pilot episode
Jesus vs. Santa well you couldn't view
the episode in your PlayStation sticking
the disc in a PC and using File Explorer
to open the video would allow you to
watch the entire pilot in all its vulgar
glory naturally this caused an uproar
among the parents who had purchased the
child friendly title so EA recalled the
game replacing it with a version that
had the dummy file removed the hidden
mountain observatory and BioShock
Infinite near the end of BioShock
Infinite players are led to an area with
a lot of lighthouses in an endless ocean
the trippy site but if you're on a PC
and able to turn off the game's clipping
which allows you to walk through Rob
you can fly through the ocean and land
in mountainous terrain there are snowy
cliffs and a bridge that leads to an
observatory in an area that looks
straight out of Skyrim when you explore
the observatory you'll find a purple
door but if you open that door you fall
into an infinite abyss and get lost in
the ether so maybe don't open the door
the unused worlds and Kingdom Hearts
birth by Sleep beloved for their amazing
visuals the Kingdom Hearts games allow
players to explore their favorite Disney
and Square Enix worlds but a few of
those worlds were cut from Kingdom
Hearts birth by sleep after basic
versions had already been created such
as the unfinished jungle book world
while there aren't many backgrounds
there are lots of cool structures and
terrain including King Louise temple
complete with his throne full adult
minigame in grand theft auto san andreas
while the Grand Theft Auto franchise is
designed for older teens and adults some
players got more than they bargained for
when some gamers discovered a built-in
sex minigame that was buried in its code
and cut from the finished version of GTA
san andreas called the hot coffee mod
players could follow up a successful
date with their girlfriend by playing a
mini game where you have to control your
characters rhythm and even change sexual
positions to fill up the excitement bar
like some kind of bizarre x-rated
version of Guitar Hero
every day naturally parents and ratings
boards freaked out when they learned of
the mini-game which caused the ESRB to
rear eight san andreas adults only
the developers recalled a game and
issued a new version which removed all
the content from the minigame and also
created a patch to disable it in PC
version that wasn't enough to completely
save them from the fallout however and
take-two ended up paying out over a
million dollars in class-action lawsuits
and other civil suits related to the mod
today original copies of the game are
collector's item and a new sealed copy
of the original hot copy capable san
andreas himself for $75 or more
dismemberment mode in Star Wars Jedi
Knight Jedi Academy considering how
deadly lightsabers are you'd think more
people would actually get killed by them
in Star Wars games but usually you just
can't do that unless of course you know
the cheat code for the original version
of Jedi Knight Jedi Academy that unlocks
dismemberment mode unsurprisingly
dismemberment mode allows players to
hack their opponents up with a
lightsaber just be careful once the mode
is turned on the player can also be
dismembered of course there are benefits
to going out like that and correctly
done I shall become more powerful and
possibly imagine - world in Super Mario
Brothers as you probably know each level
in Super Mario Brothers is numbered
according to the world you're in 1 1 2 1
etcetera but did you know there's
actually a - world that's right if you
know the right trick you can reach a
world that's simply numbered - one which
is how it got its nickname among players
just what you'll get in - world depends
on your platform on the NES you'll get
sent to a world that looks identical to
underwater world 7 - but the level can't
be finished as the final pipe will
simply send you back to the start of the
level in the Japanese Famicom version
though finishing - world brings you to -
2 world and then - 3 world before
restarting the entire game in hard mode
missingno and pokemon red and blue
missingno is the hidden pokemon that
players can find in pokemon red and blue
you can obtain it through a number of
glitches in the game one being the
infamous old man glitch first talk to
the old man north of Viridian City and
get him to show you how to catch a
Pokemon
after the demonstration fly to Cinnabar
Island and use surf to travel up and
down the eastern coast you
counter a number of Pokemon with a
chance to find missing no because it's a
glitched Pokemon your game experience
could get walking but weird pixels and
strange item duplications are a small
price to pay for catching the infamous
glitch Pokemon missing though unfinished
world in Final Fantasy 15 episode dusk a
before Final Fantasy 15 officially hit
the shelves at the end of November 2016
Square Enix made a large playable demo
titled episode dusk a available via an
exclusive download code in 2015 it
included a glowing blue barrier which
kept you from leaving the demo area
unless of course you figured out the
in-game exploit
if you got hit by a car near the barrier
it would bounce you right through to the
other side where a giant world of
dinosaurs and titans awaits
unfortunately if you did anything that
would autosave your game it would
corrupt the file but hey that's the risk
you take when you're a maverick or when
you're doing your best terminator
impression did your main call nightmare
sequence in freddy fish in this junior
adventure for ages 3 to 8 you play as
Freddy a plucky little yellow fish who
is accompanied by his best buddy Luthor
on a mission to track down the thieves
who stole the kelp feed sounds charming
right up until you enter a cheat code
that triggers a nightmare world where
Freddy offers Luther up as a sacrifice
to Eddie to eel who gleefully eats
Luther alive turns out it's just
Freddy's twisted daydream but that's not
actually any better lord of the pies in
Dragon Age Inquisition as awesome as
Dragon Age Inquisition is it also
contains more than a few bugs and
glitches one of which causes you to
occasionally fall through the floor of
your castle stronghold but while Bioware
didn't actually fix this problem they
did at least hide an easter egg down
there in the form of Lord of the pies a
huge smiling pie wearing a top hat
because if you can't have quality
control at least you can have a
terrifying pie developer test level in
Sonic Adventure 2 when Sonic Adventure 2
battle first came out for the Gamecube
fans soon discovered that you could
access a secret developer test level by
using the correct code on an action
replay device when the game was ported
to ps3 and xbox360 in 2012 the
developers never bothered to remove the
secret level
probably because it's actually pretty
cool it's not a lot to it but it's still
a fun little area to visit and play
around with the physics of Sonic the
secret brothel and Final Fantasy 7 the
honeybee Inn in Final Fantasy 7 is a
building where lonely men seek
companionship from ladies and B costumes
while players can only access a few
rooms there are a few areas that were
only accessible in the original Japanese
release among the hidden areas are an
employee room waiting room and Lobby
these rooms even feature characters that
had completed dialogue but are never
seen in the main game you know maybe
it's for the best that young gamers
weren't allowed to explore a beat themed
brothel the nether space in World of
Warcraft for over a decade
intrepid World of Warcraft players have
been finding ways to exploit the
sometimes buggy walls and ceilings of
the cars and raid in order to slip
outside the castle once you're out
there's lots of things to do like
explore a nearby ogre village or view
the smiley face left by developers the
main draw though is the unfinished zone
called nether space not only can you
explore some big floating rocks from the
sky you can also use a bug to walk right
up the wall and get to the last boss
skipping the entire massive Karazhan
raid for anyone who ever suffered
through the chess match sequence this
one glitch is just begging to be
exploited the secret treasure trove in
fallout 4 and the PC version of Fallout
4 you can access a secret room that
houses every item in the game by
entering a secret developer code inside
there are foot lockers cooking stations
crafting stations a terminal and enough
rows of power armor suits to make
Ironman jealous
we recommend loading up on everything
you can while strapping on the xo1 power
armor the best in the game it might look
like a hoarder but no one will say
anything when you're rocking that power
armor equipment room in the Elder
Scrolls v skyrim just like they did in
fallout 4
the folks at bethesda also hid a secret
equipment room in skyrim which you can
access on pc by entering some cheat
codes that will teleport you to a room
where all your item hoarding dreams can
come true
there's one cache though there are so
many items in the room that's simply
loading the loot list when you open a
chest can crash some computers now we
know why how wouldn't open that door you
knew the other side was filled with
magic axes
open the pod bay doors oh I'm sorry
Danny I'm afraid I can't do that thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all the school stuff we know
you love to
[Music]